Well,
protests erupting at
the Tennessee state capitol
after the shooting at that Nashville
school
killed three children,
nine years old and three adults.
The people that you see here
yelling no action,
no peace they're lawmakers.
And while protesters were outside
the chamber demanding action on
control, inside,
those lawmakers took over
the session with bullhorns
and now they are facing
possible removal from office.
On Monday,
there were more protests in the
chamber, this time over the poss
removal of three Democratic lawm
that vote, by the way, to decide
if they're going to lose their j
That vote happens tomorrow.
One of those lawmakers is Repres
Justin Jones.
He posted this video to social m
and says it shows Republican
State Representative Justin Laff
pushing him and grabbing his pho
Police are reportedly
looking into that matter.
I should note that Representativ
Lafferty has put out a statement
saying, quote, Jones came to my
and as I turned,
he shoved his phone into my face
and in a threatening manner.
I reacted as anyone would attemp
to characterize
this as anything else are mislea
and false.
With me now is Democratic State
Representative Justin Jones,
who represents Nashville
representing Jones.
Thank you very much.
I want to keep our eye focused o
what's happening. Right.
We wanted
to explain that confrontation
to our to our viewers.
But you're
at risk of losing your job tomor
if you lose your job
for taking the floor
and the way you did to call for
more action on guns.
Will it have been worth it?
Well, thank you so much
for having me on today.
And I think I mean, it's
morally insane that a week
after a mass shooting took
six precious lives in my communi
here in Nashville,
My colleagues on the other side
of the aisle,
their first action is not to tak
to rein
in this
proliferation of weapons of war
in our streets,
but it's to expel their colleagu
for standing with our constituen
And so this is not just about lo
my job is about silence.
The voices of over 70,000 people
in my district
all together that three of us
represent, over 200,000 people
whose voices are being taken
and silenced by a party
that is acting like authoritaria
I mean, it's very concerning,
and it represents a clear
and present danger
to democracy all across this nat
that's in trouble, us all.
So the response from
the Republican speaker
says that your actions actually
took the focus off
the victims of that shooting.
Those six victims took
the focus off their families.
This is a pair of tweets from ou
I took took the focus off
the voices of other protesters.
And I wonder how you respond to
But we went up to the well
because our people
were continually silenced.
Protesters were silenced.
The speaker of the House
refused to let any members
speak on the issue of guns.
So he he shut down Democratic de
And so we found a way to get in
to get in good trouble.
And John, Lewis called it
because that's what was needed,
that he was shutting the microph
off the movement of the people.
And that's why we had a megaphon
because he shut off
the microphone on the people.
And the speaker of the House is
is now once again
trying to silence voices,
those trying
to oust us,
voices of opposition, voices
trying to hold him accountable
for his proliferation of guns
that he promotes and his policie
And so what are you going to do
if you lose your seat?
Meaning you lose that megaphone,
You lose your vote the three of
Well, this is not about us indiv
This is about silencing a moveme
And so
I believe that this is unconstit
that our state
Constitution, Article two gives
represent us the right to dissen
from and protest against legisla
and actions
that are injurious to the people
Article two.
Section 27.
And so,
you know,
we believe that we were acting t
of our state constitution
in the United States Constitutio
to voice the concerns
and grievances of our constituen
That's why thousands of people
gathered with
with us on Thursday,
once again and Monday
and they'll be back this Thursda
when we were ousted
when they threatened to oust thi
because the people are saying
that this is an attack on democr
This is an attack on the voice
calling for action
to rein in this proliferation
of weapons of war on our streets
And so this is
this is to concern
people all across the nation.
If they can silence lawmakers,
they can silence anybody,
you know, anyone else.
That's interesting.
That's going to be
it sounds like your legal argume
to fight this expulsion
article to Section 27.
I'll just say for our viewers
and get your response finally.
Article two,
Section 12 of the Tennessee
Constitution says that very clea
that House
members representatives can be p
for disorderly behavior.
And that's what they say you wer
And I just
want to know that
this is only the third expulsion
since the Civil War
in the Tennessee House
of Representatives.
The last expulsion
was for sexual harassment.
22 counts in 2016
reps and of Jeremy Durham
that expulsion
before that in 1980
was for a recording of a lawmake
taking $1,000 bribe for his vote
And so they're saying that our a
of first amendment activity
of standing with our constituent
the many common sense
gun control is equal and equival
to those crimes and unethical be
That's what they're saying.
And it sets a very dangerous pre
that any voice of opposition or
can be ousted
from the from from a democratic
democratically elected body.
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to step on you the
A little bit of a delay.
But look, I know you're the youn
lawmaker in the state House righ
I know you ran largely
because of gun violence.
We appreciate your time.
And, of course,
we'll be watching very closely t
to see
what happens in that expulsion v
Tennessee Representative
Jones, thank you.